we're here on Hollywood Boulevard and
we're gonna figure out exactly how much
people know about this week's pop
culture question number one who stopped
out the unicorn way for their Good
Morning America appearance brilliant I
have no idea
China rock that would be blac Chyna
Caitlyn Jenner
no no it's blac Chyna blac Chyna was
dating Rob Kardashian they had a big
falling out what would you say to Rob
Kadesh which classic Nickelodeon cartoon
is getting a brand-new movie this fall's
nooner it's a cartoon you can't say
Rugrats that's not the right answer is
actually Hey Arnold let's go I'm good
out out to universe we don't want the
Rugrats which celebrity baby released
their first rap last week dj khaled son
i don't blow ivy why he will shoes boom
Shakalaka boom Shakalaka boom shoes he
got bars
yeah bars for days so we have a couple
of questions and these are like
throwback so think back to 2007 what
song was holding onto the number one
spot in the title of song of the summer
on the Billboard charts ten years ago
today ten years ago good girl gone bad
or jay-z umbrella it was Rihanna's
Umbrella it was on the number one charts
for seven weeks kudos kudos you know
used to date Drake currently dating a
billionaire yes I know about pop culture
she has a new song called wild thoughts
[Music]